hello everyone uh this next game was
played in 2011. it was the croatian team
championship finals
and uh actually this game was played by
me i played the
against an international master also
from croatia and uh at the time this
game was played i was rated around 2000
and
my opponent was an international master
rated around 24
100. and this game perfectly illustrates
how not
everything in chess is about good moves
and i prepared for this game uh i mean i
prepared
about two or three hours i you know
prepared openings for my opponent
and uh studied his uh style a bit
uh but as i knew that he would play
knight to f3 on the first move
it's pretty hard to prepare for someone
who plays knight to f3 on the first move
uh so my opponent was white and uh i was
playing with the black pieces
so let's see this game we have knight to
f3 a knight to f6
uh g3 uh g6 we have b3
i played bishop to g7 uh bishop to b2
and now
castles and this is something like uh
this is a already opening uh something
like a
nimzo larsen variation we have a bishop
to g2
i played d5 c4 c6
my opponent castled knight b to d7
he played queen to c2 e6 and
d4 and here probably the best plan for
me
would have been to to play b6 bishop b7
and continue
to play normal uh but i played knight to
e4 as i saw some games that he played
and
uh some of the games turned out pretty
good for black
he went knight knight b to d2 uh i
played f5
and uh here he played b4 and i didn't
really
understand the idea uh about this b4
uh as it seemed like a weird move i
thought he would
probably transfer the the game to the
queen side play rook b1 and push a4 and
maybe b5
uh but i didn't really think that it
mattered this b4 move
so i simply continued to play i played
b6
and i was ready to play bishop to b7 and
push c5 and
well i would wait for him to to see what
his plan was
but this b6 was actually a great blunder
as he played c captures on d5 and it was
only now that i realized what i have
done
as as you can see that now i can't
really capture with
with the e pawn if he captures here on
d5 then he simply captures queen
captures on c6
so after this c captures on d5 i have to
capture with the c
pawn and so i did it's pretty much
forced if i don't want to
be down upon i played c captures on d5
and
here my opponent played queen to c6 and
as you can see he's attacking my rook on
a8
and also my pawn on e6 and
i was very sad i mean i knew i knew this
would happen but
uh it all came so quickly this was like
move 13 and uh
i i've been preparing for the game
longer longer than i've actually played
the game and here i went into a deep
thing and i was thinking for about 45
minutes maybe even more
and my opponent got up from the table he
came back to the table then he got up
from the table again and he was you know
walking around the tournament hall
watching some games
and uh here i thought about a lot of
ideas i thought about bishop to a6 maybe
giving up my e6 pawn for some counter
play but i
it didn't really seem good uh but one
thing i knew is that
if i allow queen captures on e6 that i
can pretty much surrender the game
and there was no way to save both the
rook and the e6 pawn
so after about 45 to 15 minutes uh
when my opponent came back to the table
i played uh queen to e7
and he was it was like he was very
disgusted with this move i played
as uh i decided to defend the e6 pawn
and
let him grab my rook here on a8 and
i played queen e7 i grabbed my
cigarettes i went to the bar
i ordered a cup of coffee and you know i
just
drank my coffee and i was waiting for
him to make a move to capture the rook
and in this position he actually took
even more than i did on the previous
move he was
thinking for like 55 minutes maybe even
an hour i think it was something less
than an hour
and i saw him make a move and when i got
back
back to the table i saw the move queen
to a4 and i was like
why didn't why didn't he take the rook
and you know i did have some ideas of
what to play if he captures the rook but
mostly my plan was to
to resign the game as i saw that if
for example queen captures rook i had
some ideas like maybe knight to c5 and
try and trap the queen using bishop to
a6
but the queen would always wiggle out
but uh
he also probably saw something like this
and uh well
he he used too much calculation and in
the end uh he
he decided it was best not to grab the
rook and uh
i don't know even now i think it was
maybe due to due to his rating
he was more than 400 rating points above
me
so uh i guess he thought that whatever
he plays
he's still gonna beat me uh but uh
at least this way he he won't grab a
rook and then lose the queen
so maybe that's the reason why he didn't
take the rook
so in this position he actually played
queen to a4 and i was really
i was i didn't know what to say here uh
and i immediately played b5
so i decided to sacrifice this pawn and
go straight
straight into the the end game he played
queen chapters on b5
i played rook to b8 uh he played queen
to
a5 and i played quick uh knight captures
on d2 we have knight captures on d2 and
now queen captures some b4
so going straight straight for the end
game he can't uh grab a pawn here
because his bishop is hanging so
he played the queen captures on b4 and
uh i
recaptured row captures on b4 and this
did allow bishop to a3 but i was
actually going for this
uh so i played uh rook captures on d4
grabbing a pawn
and he took my rook uh bishop captures
an f8 and king captures on f8 and okay
he is
up in exchange but i'm up upon and uh i
have the bishop pair
and this will this will prove to be okay
uh we have knight to b3 attacking my
rook a rook to a4
rook to c1 uh now uh
first knight to c the knight to b6
protecting the bishop so i couldn't
really grab another pawn here
uh he defends the pawn rook to c2 and
now knight to c4
we have rook after c1 he doubles up on
the c file but this
doesn't really worry me as he can never
open up the c file here
i play king the king 37 getting my king
into the game
we have e3 king 36 bishop to f1 now
attacking my knight and now bishop to a6
okay
i'm still not letting him open up the c
file
knight to d2 attacking my knight and now
king to king to c5 now protecting the
knight one more time
rook to b1 he wants to infiltrate my
position using the b
file but i simply play bishop to b5 and
not allowing him
he goes knight to b3 with check i go
back king to d6
we have knight to c1 uh a6 now
cementing that bishop on b5 rook to b3
we have h6 uh knights to e2
uh knight to a5 rook to b1 rook to a3
knight to d4 and i think it was
in this position that he actually uh
offered a draw
uh but i actually declined the draw as i
uh
i thought if if he didn't beat me when i
gave him a whole rook
i really want to win this game and i
played bishop captures on d4
he played bishop captures on b5 and here
i played bishop captures on e3
so f captures an e3 and only now do i
recapture this bishop on b5 so a
captures on b5 and
rook captures on b5 and here i play rook
the c
uh a knife to c4 and now i'm attacking
this pawn one more time
i mean twice and he can't defend this
pawn so
he played a king to f2 and i just
grabbed the pawn knight captures an e3
and he's still up the exchange but uh
i'm up
i'm up two pawns so this is well pretty
much in equal position
uh he played rook to b6 check i played
king to e5 and here he played uh rook c
to c6
threatening to grab my e6 pawn and in
this position i played knight to g4 with
check and here we agreed to a draw
uh because whatever he does i'm gonna
grab all of these pawns and
well i can simply just continue checking
him so
it was it was a disposition that we
agreed to a draw
and this was the strongest opponent i
ever drew against uh
my first draw against an international
master and
uh yeah it's uh it's definitely
proof that uh it's not all about making
good moves
sometimes there's uh there's a a little
bit of psychology involved
as uh like i said in this position after
after he played this b4 move and i
played b6 this terrible blunder
and queen to c6 uh
here if i if i allowed him to capture
this
e6 pawn uh my position would have been
destroyed
like immediately but by playing queen to
e7 which is
which is a terrible move i actually
managed to to draw a game against an
international master
so yeah uh that's it uh you were
you were all asking me to show one game
that i played so
what better game than than the one where
i managed
to trick my opponent so yeah
thank you all for watching as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and uh have you ever played a a game
like this uh
for i mean in classical chess in
classical time controls
so yeah thank you for watching and i'll
see you soon